inflation data is now out the
cpi number came in at 5.3 percent uh and
the core inflation if you take out food
and energy came in that four percent now
if we go ahead and we look at this we
have so many charts the best business
show research team we were hard at work
all morning long finding all of these
charts so first let's start with the cpi
urban consumer index what this
essentially is showing is people within
cities here is the cpi it's real high
there's tons of people who are
celebrating the fact that it's 5.3
percent now if you are a genius like us
you can easily see that we are still at
incredibly elevated levels this chart
goes all the way back to 2015 and you
can see in 16 17 18 and 19 we were
hovering around plus or minus two
percent that is the fed's target two
percent they were doing somewhat of a
good job keeping it around two percent
but then all of a sudden in 2020 we had
this massive dip because of the covid
pandemic and the economic carnage that
ensued because of the
unconstitutional government mandated
lockdowns and what we had to do was use
monetary and fiscal tools to drive
liquidity into the market and boy did we
drive we drove liquidity into the market
so well then in 2021 we now have over
five percent
inflation in cpi metric now as many of
you know there is a term that keeps
getting thrown out there called
transitory and that term transitory is a
classic intellectual sleight of hand and
what do i mean by that if you look up
the definition of transitory there is
two words that make up the definition of
transitory not permanent that's it there
are no quantifiable metrics around the
term transitory it is just not permanent
and so the begs the question is how high
can inflation be and for how long until
we can negate the fact that it's
transitory if inflation stays at five
percent for a year does that mean that
inflation was transitory or not what if
it stays at sustained levels at over
three percent for three or four years
does that mean it was transitory or not
what happens if we have two and a half
three four percent inflation for five
six seven years is that transitory
nobody knows it's a term that means
nothing it's literally just a magical
word that can be twisted to support any
narrative that those in charge want to
make it and so as long as you continue
to say it's transitory it's transitory
it's like promising
a better future i promise it's going to
go down but the beauty of the word
transitory for those in charge is also
that
as long as you are measuring inflation
simply by the rate of change and not
looking at the actual aggregate
inflation you know that it can't go up
forever you're not going to get
compounded inflation of five percent
this year the next year it's seven
percent the year after that it's 10
percent because that would mean that it
was actually accelerating and
compounding at a very very aggressive
rate instead what is a better
measurement is if prices are being
increased right now the cost of goods
and services going up they're not going
to lower those prices in the future
there's nothing transitory about the
price increases they are here to stay
and likely we will continue to see price
increases in the future so the fact that
we focus on the rate of change rather
than the aggregate change is one slight
of hand and then the term transitory of
course the magical word that everyone
likes to point to transitory is simply
something that cannot be measured it
cannot be negated it cannot be proven
not to be true and so as long as we
continue to use the word transitory it's
a way for those in charge to hide the
fact that inflation is here and
inflation is ravaging the bottom 45
percent of paul of the population so the
next chart that we have is the
core
inflation in the urban
metropolitan areas and when you look at
the cpi urban consumers taking out food
and energy which of course food and
energy those must not be very big parts
of your expenses
we see it's at four percent again same
exact story 2016 17 18 19 there was
around two percent but then all of a
sudden we exploded upwards in 2021 and
we're still sitting around four percent
and people are celebrating the fact that
we have this little dip here but as you
can see we had a little dip earlier in
2021 as well and then we exploded
upwards and so what we are seeing is
still about double
the metric
of core inflation it's usually around
two we're at four percent i don't know
why we're celebrating we're still it's
twice as bad as it normally is not good
so where exactly is all of the inflation
coming from we've got this table here
that we outsourced to zero hedge thank
you guys so much we appreciate the
partnership that we have uh and what
they showed here is this is actually
each component of inflation broken down
you can see here in august what gained
and what lost so if we go down and we
look at the things that lost that 2.1
percent is fuel is down 2.1 in august
month over month growth and then you can
see used cars and trucks are down 1.5
you can see that medical care costs are
down 0.2 percent and then transportation
services are down 2 as well in august
but if you look at the unadjusted 12
months ending in august we still have
absolutely insane numbers
energy in total is up 25 year-over-year
if you look at things like energy
commodities up 41 percent you look at
gasoline up 42 percent and fuel oil is
up 33
energy is off the chain if you then go
and you look at things like utilities
gas services they're up 21
absolutely bonkers and then of course if
you go and you go ahead and you look at
the used cars and trucks we are still up
31 almost 32 percent year over year now
that is insane but those are the big
kind of headline numbers those are the
video game numbers as i like to call
them if we go ahead and we simply look
at other data points like let's i don't
know start with all items up 5.3 that's
still a really really big number 5.3
percent is insane from an inflation
standpoint food is up 3.7
if inflation is supposed to be 2 and
food is up 3.7 food is up almost twice
as much in price as the fed rate target
then if we look at food at home we're
not even talking about grocery store
stuff this is food at home up three
percent if you look at energy in or i'm
sorry food away from home is up 4.7
so literally whether you're eating out
or you are eating in you're paying more
money as we know those at the bottom of
the population
they have food as an outsized portion of
their monthly expenses and so when you
increase prices three four almost five
percent whether they're eating at home
or out at a restaurant it is incredibly
painful for those families if you then
look at energy services including
electricity and utility gas that's up
8.6
8.6
energy
one of the big costs that people pay on
a monthly basis and then when you start
to even go into commodities without
including food or energy you can see
that just traditional commodities up
seven percent new vehicles up seven
point six percent apparel is up four
percent how in the hell are somebody
supposed to live in this country they
work an hourly job they don't get a pay
raise and food is up 3.7
clothing's up 4.2 their electricity
bills up 5
everything is just going up and to the
right and there is no end in sight
shelter one of my favorite ones is up
2.8
and if you look at transportation
services up four percent so literally
everything that you spend money on for
the most part is up
and so of course if everything is going
up you're going to be in a worse
financial position if you live paycheck
to paycheck and you save in cash now why
are some of the things in august right
there is some good data points in here
but why is some of it going down in
august well according to dr julia
coronado the delta variant was a very
big part of the story if you look at
everything from lodging away from home
meaning if you're traveling or airline
fare everything was down in august you
can see there on the far right uh it's
all dipping why the narrative around the
delta variant which by the way all of
the covid data i don't want to get too
deep into it but i recently read on the
cdc website they don't actually test if
it's the delta variant or a different
variant it's just the covit or not covet
the delta variant narrative took over in
the mainstream press and that caused
less and less people to travel so if
less people are traveling because they
fear delta then what ends up happening
is of course airfares are down and also
lodging away from home is down so you
get what appears to be a slowdown but
instead is it a slowdown because the
economy is actually improving or is it
more concerns around the health crisis
you decide
next up we have liz young who uh i
believe is the head of investment
strategy at sofi uh she's from so far
she's an excellent follow on twitter
highly suggest you follow her uh she had
this tweet this morning that said cpi x
food and energy core inflation month
over month is back down to pre-crisis
levels the used cars are down 1.5 car
and truck rentals down eight and a half
and airfare down nine percent
contributing to the slowdown some of
this is a pause
from delta but a cooling in multiple
spots and so again there is a
belief that some of this is a periodic
pause because people were fearing that
delta varian if all of a sudden those
fears go away all the activity comes
back and we'll be right back ripping and
roaring with that inflation now use cars
and trucks if we go ahead and we take a
look at this this is like a video game
i mean just literally how high can we go
doesn't matter if there's a little
slight drawback we can still explode
higher as we did after that kind of
september to uh february drawdown in the
prices and then bam we just exploded in
march used car salesmen were getting
rich and you weren't that's what was
happening used car salesmen literally
they don't have enough demand they got
they can't keep cars on the lot because
they are absolutely printing cash if you
got to use car dealership
shout out to you because you are getting
rich at the expense of everybody else if
you go ahead and you look at the used
car prices month over month you can see
that back in february was that last big
negative drawdown where we had a minus
point nine percent then since then we
have just seen month after month after
month of positive growth including two
ten baggers in there that's right april
was a 10 month over month growth in the
price june also saw more than 10 growth
month over month of used car prices
august we went back and we had a little
bit of relief again we can celebrate the
relief of minus 1.5 used cars but it
doesn't matter the price is still so
insanely high compared to where it was
pre-pandemic and so peter schiff who's
coming on the show in a little bit to
talk about all of this inflation data
had a great tweet this morning he said
for the first time in nine months cpi
rose less than expected but the point
three percent growth in august
still annualizes to almost four percent
the actual year-over-year rise is 5.3
percent and the annualized year-to-date
jump is 6.3 percent ridiculously low
owner's equivalent rent continues to
mask a far larger inflation problem so
when you start to think about this you
can look at the relative growth or
contraction from july to august and
there are reasons why some people are
celebrating in certain parts of the
economy but at the same time it does not
change the fact that we still have over
five percent cpi we have four percent
core inflation and if you start to
annualize some of the numbers we're
seeing in august it is still very very
nasty and so if you go ahead and you
look neil irwin here's got this consumer
price inflation all in one chart and
it's worth noting that the plus 0.3
percent per month is sustained for a
year works out to 3.7 annual inflation
well above the fed target even adjusting
for cpi versus pce differences and so
again this chart is showing that yes the
months between april and june were real
real real crazy
but we still are pretty crazy today and
so it's easy to look backwards in the
rearview mirror and say well at least
it's not as crazy as in april or may or
in june but that doesn't mean that we're
still in a good situation
and so if we go when we look at jen's
nordvig who said that he likes to look
at the inflation data in a median sense
because there's so many outliers so can
you basically take the center of the
distribution across all 82 categories
and equally weight them he thinks that
this gives you a much better idea of the
month-over-month inflation growth and so
if you could see this here
we're not going lower if you actually
take that median weighted
distribution
inflation is just as high as it's been
throughout this entire thing
and so what we are watching is in this
specific chart is a great example that
the data can be manipulated however you
want you can make the data say whatever
you want and so all he did was took the
exact same data points and he calculated
it differently and he shows actually
inflation is just as high as it was last
month there's been no change
but if you calculated it a different way
if you manipulate it if you start to
take things out like food and energy you
can make it say whatever you want but
that doesn't change the fact that prices
are much higher and those that have
increased their prices are not going to
lower them and last but not least for
those that are holding cash those
people who haven't been listening the
people who haven't gotten the education
the purchasing power of the us dollar is
at an all-time low that's correct world
record low
dollar purchasing power as you can see
here going all the way back to 1913. we
continue to see the erosion of the
purchasing power of the us dollar
at the bottom there you can see all
sorts of different items what one dollar
buys you
it used to buy you let's see uh 20 20
20 bottles of coca-cola in 1944 one
dollar would buy you that today one
dollar is uh one mcdonald's coffee in
2020. uh one dollar used to buy you 30
hershey's chocolate bars in 1913. if you
think about that for a second one dollar
used to buy you 30 hershey's chocolate
bars then in 1929 i bought you ten rolls
of toilet paper for one dollar
ten rolls of toilet paper one dollar
nineteen twenty nine if you go ahead and
you look joe loves pretzels 10 bags of
pretzels in 1953
one dollar 10 bags of pretzels do you
then go to 1971 you used to be able to
buy 17 oranges for one single dollar
pretty damn cool in 1997 you could buy
four grapefruits in 2008 you could buy
two lemons and today today you can get
one mcdonald's coffee small of course
because they're not gonna sell you the
big one for only one dollar what's up
guys bang bang it's your boy pomp thanks
so much for watching the best business
show our goal is to make this the
largest most actionable business show in
the world and to do that we need your
help we've partnered with sofi as our
exclusive sponsor because they have a
piece of software that we think will
help you take the information that we
share on a daily basis and make it
actionable we want every single person
to pursue and achieve financial security
and financial freedom in order to do
that you gotta act and sofi allows you
to do it so you can go to sofi.com
today you can open up an account and
when you open up an account you can
invest in all sorts of different types
of assets etfs individual stocks ipos
bitcoin cryptocurrencies they even have
an automated investing function if you
want to invest sofi can help you they've
got a couple of different offers that
you can benefit from the first open an
invest account and they'll give you up
to a thousand bucks for free kind of a
no-brainer second is if you go on and
you buy one of the cryptocurrencies that
they offer they'll go ahead and they'll
give you ten dollars of bitcoin for free
and third some of you are saying i
already have a brokerage account i
already have an account somewhere else
right now you can get up to five
thousand dollars for transferring your
account that's right sofi doesn't care
where your current account is but if you
transfer from that place to sofi they'll
pay you up to five thousand dollars for
doing it why wouldn't you do it it's up
to five thousand dollars for free head
on over to sofi.com today to get started
and come back tomorrow and watch more of
the best business show together we're
going to build the biggest show in the
world
[Music]